die entscheidende Woche über Krieg oder
Frieden in Europa hat begonnen
vielleicht letzte Chance für eine
diplomatische Lösung der Ukraine Krise
gibt 24 Stunden versuchen wir mal das
einzuordnen das wichtigste nach
Gesprächen mit Frankreichs Präsident
macron haben sich russlands Präsident
Putin und US-Präsident beiden
grundsätzlich zu einem zweier Gipfel
bereit erklärt die Außenminister der
beiden Länder sollen das am Donnerstag
vorbereiten Voraussetzungen für die
Amerikaner es kommt vorher nicht zu
einer Invasion das allerdings ist nach
wie vor nicht ausgeschlossen denn anders
als angekündigt ziehen die Russen nicht
aus Weißrussland ab und nach US
Geheimdienstinformationen haben dich
rund die Hälfte der mehr als 150.000
russischen Soldaten an der Grenze zur
Ukraine bereits im kampfformationen
aufgestellt und könnten innerhalb
weniger Tage einen Angriff starten dazu
braucht ist möglicherweise ein Vorwand
ein vermeintlicher Angriff von
ukrainischer Seite etwa auf pro
russische Rebellen in der Grenzregion
und dort kommt es in der Tat immer
wieder zu Auseinandersetzungen wie auch
unsere Reporter Paul ronsheimer erfahren
hat der dort für uns unterwegs ist
Sonntag
morgensheimer unterwegs in der
Ostukraine dort an der Front spricht er
gerade mit ukrainischen Soldaten über
eine russische Invasion als Geschosse
einschlagen
[Musik]
ganz in der Nähe
lass uns lieber Entdeckung gehen
immer wieder neue Einschläge Lauterbach
die Soldaten geben jetzt das Zeichen
schnell Schutz suchen
also durch die Gräben hindurch ab in den
nächsten Bunker
[Musik]
gerade eben hat es hier die direkt an
unserer Position nur wenige hundert
Meter entfernt Einschläge gegeben und
wir mussten dann mit den ukrainischen
Soldaten hier in Untergrund sozusagen in
ihr Versteck um uns vor weiteren
möglichen Attacken von Pro russischer
Seite zu schützen das was wir hier
erleben gerade in diesem Moment passiert
hier jeden Tag und jede Nacht und die
ukrainischen Soldaten wissen nie wann
gegen sie geschossen wird wann sie
angegriffen werden nach einigen Minuten
etwas durchatmen Paul ronsheimer fragt
dann drehe der mit seinen 23 Jahren für
die Ukraine kämpft ob ihm die tausenden
russischen Panzer diese riesige Armee
denn gar keine Angst macht
keine Sorge die haben Panzer und gute
Ausrüstung aber wir werden die hier
stoppen wir haben keine Angst und weiter
durch die Ostukraine mit dem
schaukelnden Auto vorbei an Häusern mit
frischen Kriegsspuren
dieses Dach nach einem granateneinschlag
zerstört notdürftig wird jetzt das Loch
gestopft im eiskalten Wind
und wieder geht es an der Front entlang
dort wo immer Beschuss droht auch hier
leben Menschen Kinder
paul ronsheimer trifft Katja vierfache
mama warum gehen sie nicht weg sie haben
doch vier Kinder ich kann doch nirgendwo
anders hin nirgendwo wartet jemand auf
mich und glauben sie dass Putin sich
längst zum Krieg entschieden hat fragt
Paul ronsheimer
klar das hat er schon lange entschieden
wir haben gerade mit jemandem auf der
russischen Seite gesprochen die haben
jetzt die general Mobilmachung verkündet
und alle Frauen und Kinder müssen raus
und die warten jetzt gerade in Bussen an
der russischen Grenze die sind geschockt
[Musik]
ja und wir haben ihn vor kurz gesehen
paul ronsheimer ist uns jetzt live
zugeschaltet direkt von der Front
sozusagen auf ein Gott sei Dank ein
Krieg noch nicht begonnen hat aber die
Provokation dort vor Ort Paul sind
natürlich die ganze Zeit da und das ist
ja die große Sorge wird die Ukraine das
so gelassen ertragen wie das in den
Bildern gerade auch zum Ausdruck kam
oder womöglich zurückschlagen wollen und
damit Putin den Vorwand liefern den er
womöglich sucht
du keine charmee wird alles versuchen
diesen Vorwand nicht zu liefern aber
Thomas eins muss man sagen der Krieg ist
hier wo ich bin längst angekommen seit
vielen vielen Jahren ich stehe hier
direkt an der Front hier hinter diesen
kaputt gebrochen
im Ersten Weltkrieg in den Film und die
Soldaten die dort durchlaufen sie werden
immer wieder beschossen
seit vielen Jahren aber seit ein paar
Tagen seitdem nämlich die Spekulationen
oder auch die westlichen Geheimdienste
sagen putin will angreifen seitdem hat
es zugenommen und das gefährliche ist
hier vor allem dass die Front direkt
entlang von Dörfern verläuft Jörger ist
einfach eine Show hier einmal die Dörfer
das ist jetzt das Dorf hinter mir das
sind nur wenige hundert Meter und da
kommen immer wieder Mörsergranaten
ist ein ukrainischer Soldat Kosmos what
happens with your commerates today's a
girl
fighting
hier sieht man sie attackiert und ein
Soldat ist dabei ums Leben gekommen also
die Situation hier Thomas ist wahnsinnig
brenzlig aber diese ganzen menschlichen
Schicksale wir haben es eben eine
Beitrag gesehen du warst bei einer
Familie mit kleinen Kindern auch die
Menschen leben in ständige Angst wie
sehr nimmt sich das auch mit das zu
sehen das zu erleben auch als erfahrener
Kriegsreporter
ich habe das gestern gesagt weil die
richtigen Fragen dass man wirklich auch
als jemand der nicht viel betet in
diesen Tagen betet dass es nicht noch
schlimmer wird
dann wird es viele viele Zivilisten
treffen
sondern Menschen
mit
einem zwei Wochen alten Baby und
deswegen hoffe ich dass alles getan wird
dass dieser große Krieg diese große
russische Invasion verhindert werden
kann
du hast Katja angesprochen die wir im
Film gesehen haben bei aller Angst die
sie natürlich auch haben wirken doch die
Menschen ja fast schon gelassen in in
einer gewissen Weise konntest du das so
feststellen auch wenn wir den Soldaten
hören der sagt er glaubte dass er ja die
russischen Panzer aufhalten kann was ja
mehr als unrealistisch ist
besser
die Ukraine eigentlich nichts zur
Gegenwehr das hat sich verändert auch
durch die Hilfe aus den USA aus
Großbritannien und im Krieg ist es so
die Menschen gewöhnen sich daran super
Menschen und ihre Familie es ist
Normalität dass du als Mörser
Nachbarn sterben und so grausam das ist
die Menschen haben sich an diese
schreckliche Situation gewöhnt fast muss
man sagen und die Soldaten die können
nichts anderes machen als sie an den
Positionen zu stehen und ihr Land zu
verteidigen du hattest am Anfang gefragt
was ist wenn es diese Provokation gibt
natürlich gibt es auch von ukrainischer
Seite dann deine Antwort auf das was von
Separatisten Seite bzw von der
russischen Armee denn das muss man ja
einmal klar sagen dort in Donez nur
weniger 100 Meter hier von dir entfernt
da sind eben schon länger russische
Soldaten nicht als initialer Grenze
Wagner Geheimdienste Aldi das ist schon
unter Putins Kontrolle das sind Schergen
wie dort hier bereits
[Musik]
vor Ort und bis gleich ja der
ukrainische Botschafter andre Melnik der
war gestern in unserer Talk Sendung die
richtigen Fragen zu Gast und machte noch
mal klar dass die Ukraine kurz vor einem
Krieg steht und er attackierte sogar
Deutschland wir wollen uns das ganze
noch mal anschauen
ich glaube dass unsere
Fingerspitzen schon wirklich vor diesem
schrecklichen Abgrund des neuen großen
Krieges stehen und ich kann Ihnen
folgendes sagen wenn Deutschland sich
nach wie vor oder weiterhin weigen wird
und wenn Putin tatsächlicher in den
nächsten Tagen oder Wochen einmarschiert
das würde bedeuten das Versagen der
deutschen Außenpolitik das wäre eine
bankrotte Erklärung ihre Politik und die
Ukraine werden diesen Fahrrad nie
vergessen
das sind scharfe Worte wir schalten live
zu Vitali Klitschko dem Xbox Weltmeister
und jetzt den Bürgermeister von Kiel für
Klitschko würden sie das auch so stark
sagen eine Versagen der deutschen weil
sie die Ukraine nicht ausreichend
unterstützen
sehr wichtiges Sätze und mir auch die
sagen wir sind Ukraine ein friedliche
Volk friedliche Nation wir Drohnen keine
wir sind überhaupt nicht aggressiv zum
unserer Nachbarn was jetzt im Moment
passiert das ist eine Albtraum eine
riesige Drohung das ist ein Vision in
und in unseres Land und deswegen in
diese Situation
glaube ich müssen muss die ganze
demokratische Welt auf einer Seite
stellen und Unterstützung das Frieden
das ist die wichtigste Frage für jede
Ukraine für jede Europäer und wir
verstehen dass es in dieser Situation
dass es nur gemeinsame
Position von alle demokratische Länder
muss klar und deutlich sein kein Krieg
nur Frieden
und die wir sehen dass es eine Menge von
russisch Soldaten auf Grenze du keine
jede sprichst du dir eine mögliche
Angriff du keine in dem Fall haben wir
keine andere Wahl wir müssen uns
verteidigen wir müssen verteidigen
unsere Familien wir müssen verteidigen
unsere
Städte unsere Land und brauchen wir
Unterstützung
ich möchte auch in die Frage stellen die
ich Paul ronsheimer vorhin gestellt hat
nun kann es ja sein dass Putin es darauf
anlegt ein Vorwand zu provozieren auf
den er dann reagieren kann und sagen so
wir wurden angegriffen von Seiten der
Ukraine wie sehr werden sie ruhe
bewahren wenn sie sagen wir müssen uns
verteidigen wie sehr werden sie aber
auch Ruhe bewahren und sich auf
Provokationen nicht einlassen
ja selbstständig die Risiko Risiko von
Provokation ist groß und
deswegen die Medien muss genau klar
berichten was sind wirklich passiert
weil
jetzt heute bist du sowieso
gespannt und deswegen die jede kleine
Provokation kann eine richtig
explodieren deswegen
wegen Gedanken an Paul Rossmann Rossmann
ihr das jetzt im Moment in Osten durch
eine das ist alle internationale
Journalisten mussten klare Situation
berichten und die
ehrliche ehrliche
Situation zu beschreiben das ist sehr
wichtig auch das ist eine private Tiere
Instrumente gegen Russland die wir
schließen nicht aus dass es wird eine
große Provokation aber habe ich schon
gesagt wir Drohnen keine wir sind nicht
a wir sind bei uns in unserer Land und
wir
sind deine friedliche Volk das alles was
passiert das ist eine
wahnsinnig Spiel von russische
Federation
ihrer Stadt beschreiben 3 Millionen
Menschen leben dort wie ist es der
Alltag da jeden Tag könnte es passieren
was macht das mit den Menschen das ist
ja auch eine Art psychischer Terror der
jetzt schon stattfindet
das ist nicht nur psychische Terror
alles Leute sind möchte ich sagen nervös
und keine will das Krieg und das ist
nicht nur psychische Bildung das ist
auch finanziell dass es jetzt im Moment
die ganze wirtschaftliche Saison in
dukanes gefroren die Flüge
sehr viele
Fluggesellschaften schon seine Flüge
gecancelt nach Ukraine
das ist wirklich sehr sehr schädlich für
unsere Wirtschaft für die ganze
Situation
hoffen wir hoffen wir auf diplomatische
Weg bis diese Konflikt wird
löschen aber wenn nein dann leider haben
wir keine andere Wahl wir müssen unsere
Land unsere Familie verteidigen heute
hat die deutsche Verteidigungsministerin
gesagt dass die 5000 Helme die
Deutschland der Ukraine schicken will
versandbereit sind die könnten in drei
Tagen da sein sie waren schon mal sehr
wütend über dieses Angebot
wahrscheinlich auch jetzt für sie keine
beruhigende Nachricht
ähm ich bin nicht wütend aber das ist
der klingt das wie eine Witz wir
brauchen eine Verteidigungswaffen das
ist eine der größten mächtigste Armee
steht da auf unsere Grenze auch und mit
Drohung in Vision in du keine ich möchte
ich weiß die Deutschland deine größte
Unterstützung die Ukraine hat immer
unterstützt hat sehr viel Geld
investiert in unsere Wirtschaft für
Reformer zu machen in unser Land wieder
stark zu machen aber jetzt in diese
Situation Helme ich möchte noch einmal
bedanken dass es hilft uns sehr aber zu
verteidigen und zu verteidigen gegen
Adresse die Helme das
einfach nicht genug
wir brauchen eine moderne
Verteidigungswaffe das wenn fragen Sie
was brauchen wir das sage ich wir
brauchen eine moderne
Verteidigungswaffen und bevor eine
Adresse wird an Maschinen du keine
Russland muskelkulieren dass es wird
sehr sehr schmerzhaft sein für jede
Adresse wir sind bereit unsere Land zu
verteidigen aber dafür brauchen wir
Verteidigungs ich möchte noch einmal
bestätigen Verteidigungs machen weil wir
sind friedliche voll wie wir sind nicht
aggressiv aber müssen wir unsere Land
verteidigen unsere Familie das ist dass
es in heutige Zeit sehr wichtig für uns
Vitali Klitschko Bürgermeister von Kiew
vielen Dank für dieses Interview und
immerhin ein Zeichen der Hoffnung
möglicherweise wenn Putin und beiden
sich treffen zu einem zweiergipfel
vielleicht ist es auch noch die Woche
der Diplomatie vielen Dank Vitali
Klitschko